I am very excited to introduce Diana
cower and Diana is creator of the Youtube
Channel Physics girl. She grew up
driving tractors on a farm in Hawaii.
I think you were just in Hawaii.
Uh,
surfing's scuba diving and playing
the Ukulele. Ukulele today. I'm,
I apologize for that.
And with that training,
found your way to science
and engineering pursuits,
nicknamed happy pants in college.
I have no idea why Diana research dark
matter with Professor Jasleen Monroe as
an Undergrad at MIT and low
Mattel mentalities stars
with professor and Friable
as a post baccalaureate research fellow
at the Harvard Smithsonian Center for
Astrophysics.
Say That 10 times fast.
She worked as a software engineering
intern at GE designing mobile apps and at
Uc San Diego was a science outreach
coordinator before ultimately becoming,
you tube's physics girl fulltime.
Please welcome Diana to Google.
[inaudible]
I had really colorful pants. All
that's why I did. I had a pair of like,
they looked like hippie pants and so
one of my friends called me happy events
because of that. Excellent.
I did not know me now.
So, uh, this is definitely applied
to me when I was in high school.
Physics can send terror in the hearts
of many high school students and is a
really broad discipline.
Just like engineering is a
very blood, broad discipline.
How would you describe physics
to a middle schooler or
a middle schooler?
That was,
I don't want to think about
that as a rough time in my life.
I think it's a rough time for
everybody's like everybody. Yeah.
So the thing about physics,
like I think when,
when you think about physics as a class,
do you think about like the equations,
like you know,
Newton's equations and you think about
if you push something with a certain
forest, you're going to get a certain
acceleration. Um, but that like,
it just sounds so lame when you
describe physics like that. For me,
physics is like, it's like all the
things that you're interested in.
So for a middle schooler it's,
I dunno,
like they're interested in their
crushes and they're interested in like,
like a sports maybe or their interests
that they're starting to get, you know,
makeup, curious or things like that. Um,
so take some of those things like sports
and a soccer ball will curve because of
physics. You can explain that with
physics and then even like even makeup,
you can explain iridescence the same way
that you explain how a butterfly wing
works or why I'm thin films like
spilled oil looks kind of shiny.
Like you can explain it these everyday
things with physics and then take all
that and make something that
middleschoolers couldn't
live without like their
smartphone. Um, then on the other
side of it, there's, you know,
there's this like application stuff.
Then there's like completely
useless stuff that's really cool.
Like the fact that stars can just
explode supernovas and then become black
holes. How does that work? Physics will
tell you. And then there's like, you know,
there's, there's the fact that a ball is
really, really, if it's really smooth,
you can kick it the same way and
it'll Kern the opposite direction,
which is really cool to see. I've
got a video on it. Um, so like,
so physics does this, it's like
the useful and the useless. It,
it explains all this stuff in our world.
Like in literally explains
why the sky is blue
and going to the other
end of the spectrum now.
So why should those in Washington and
political power that control the budgets
of public research care about physics?
I mean,
I think that the,
the typical answer that you would hear
to this question is something like,
all of the advancements we've had in
stem and technology and engineering and
science,
um,
have often been thought of as like
kind of interesting but not necessarily
useful.
Like the light bulb is one of the most
famous inventions that people thought was
useless that we would never
actually need like candles there.
They're good enough, you
know. Um, but, but for me,
for me personally,
I think that that like as art is just
good enough for the sake of having arts in
our lives, the same is true of like
the pursue of fundamental science.
So humans have been curious about
our world. Like how, you know,
we ask tons of questions all the
time, like all of us, I know you do,
we were just like curious about our world.
And this has been part of being a human,
it's been part of the human
experience and civilization started.
So for me that's enough of a reason to
give funding and to pursue scientific
research. Sure. Yeah.
Well I survived computer engineering in
university and struggled a bit through
physics in high school.
What advice do you have for students
who are struggling to grasp physics
concepts? Probably more at the high school
level before they run off to college.
Well,
I would say
in addition to watching your videos,
which really does help. Yes, yes.
That's what my videos are not going to
teach you how to do your homework as much
as you email me with your homework
problems trying to ask. Um,
um,
I would say,
I would say that that,
yeah, physics like it's not,
it's never going to be easy.
Physics really is math heavy
when you get deep into it.
But like any kind of learning,
I think you have to learn how
to be a student more than you.
I have to learn the material first.
So if you're starting a class,
you'd probably want to take a look
through the syllabus and find your own
questions, like find what you are curious
about and that's the best way to learn.
So when I do my videos,
I learned so well because I have these
questions and I'm curious and that's why
I choose that video topic. So like, yeah,
as a student you can have a teacher or
a parent that's going to tell you what's
interesting and what you
need learn and they like,
you're going to take this class because
this is what's important for you to know,
but like take it back into your own hands,
like take control of your learning.
I looked through that syllabus,
find some questions that you're
interested in and you're curious about and
that's going to help guide your
learning through the class.
I think this ties this next question,
which is at some point physics went from
being a credit you had to get to being
really cool. Maybe that
happened really early. So what,
what made physics called high school
and Cooler once you got to college?
What were these questions that were
really burning in your mind that physics
started to answer?
Well, physics was always
cool for me. Like since I've,
since I took my first physics class,
it was like, this is it. Ah, um,
but I th I think probably there,
there were a ton of questions
that physics answered for me. Um,
starting with things
like why is the sky blue?
Like I found out that that blue
light scatters more and I was like,
well that's Kinda cool.
I found out in the process that the sun
emits all of the colors of visible light
in addition to some of these
other colors that are not visible.
I thought that was fascinating when I
first learned that x-rays and microwaves
and gamma rays and radio waves are all
the same thing is as visible light,
which is, which is a thing that I still
haven't got my parents to fully grasp,
but I'm trying. But when I first learned
that, I was like, you're kidding me.
Are you like, it's all light. It
haul, it has the same properties.
It's like the same phenomenon is just
that we can't see it. That was cool.
I was like,
these are things about our world that the,
I didn't know that a lot of people
don't know, but physics knows,
like we've discovered as you know,
throughout humanity,
as scientists and as curious persons,
we've discovered all these interesting
things about the world. Wait,
I had some really
awesome physics teachers,
so never underestimate the value
of like, you know, what you can,
when you can do to instill the curiosity
and the excitement on the young people
in your life.
And maybe that's if you were
talking to other physics teachers,
what about those teachers
you had made them so amazing?
I wouldn't say excitement
was a huge part of it.
Like I tell this story all
the time, but Cathy Jones, oh,
she was like miss frizzle
but like really cool. Um,
she had a ton of
experiments going on during,
during like the breaks
during recess of our classes.
So she had this one where she had a block
of ice and then a cord going over the
top of the ice and weights on either side.
And then you wait throughout the day
and we would come back in throughout the
day and see the cord,
like cutting through the ice and
then refreezing over the top.
So like midway through the day you've got
an ice block with a cord going through
the middle of it,
just from the pressure pushing down and
cutting through the ice is cool stuff.
So she was like, come and see
this all the time. Come share it.
And that's something that I have
not done as much in my life.
But now being a science communicator,
I've realized like how important it is
when you're with young people to share
something you're passionate about.
Like I dunno,
carry around a little experiment
or something and be like,
when when you're with a little kid
and be like, hey, come check this out.
Like not in a creepy way. Just like,
just like, like this is cool. Like,
Oh, okay, I've got these earrings
on. Sorry, I'm getting excited.
I've got these hearings on that.
We'll have to do a show until after
they're there, like shrunken dime.
Oh, cool. Yeah. From the video
you did on that. Yes. Cool.
Video. Go check it out. Yeah.
So like I really like wearing
these because every once
in a while I get to take
them off and show a little
kid because they're like,
they're shrunken by a giant electromagnet.
Um, put it in the middle of,
of the electromagnet and
it shrinks the quarter.
So you're like literally using a
magnet to create current and shrink.
Well it was originally a
quarter. These were dimes. Um,
but I mean earrings out of them so I
could always carry around my lens with me.
Very cool. And that ties into this cool
new video. You published a this morning,
um, which includes a maker style
project for a lightening generator. I,
I've already promised my daughter
we're going to do this summer.
How was pursuing science help you wrestle
through tough problems without giving
up? Cause he your video giving you
a lawyer a little bit, you know,
you see the video of the end result.
You don't see the three days of struggling
to make this thing actually works at
what have you learned how to science
taught you to persevere? Maybe a dog.
Oh, lovely. And more, well,
I conveniently deleted the three days of
footage where we struggled on accident.
It wasn't convenient. It was
really sad. Anyways. Um, so yeah,
this video was a homemade capacitor.
So is it a cake pan?
On the bottom is the bottom plate and
then a piece of polycarbonate for the
dielectric. And then, uh, uh,
a bowl with a piece of sheet metal on
the top for the top plate and then you
charge it up by using a PVC pipe.
Um,
we struggled a lot with not having
any innuendos in this video because,
because the PVC pipe,
you have to rub it with a paper towel
back and forth and then deposit charge
onto the bowl over and over. So, um,
something I've struggled with in
my channel on Youtube, you know,
this inviting platform, but, um, anyways,
I'm going off on a random tangent.
Bring the train back.
So this was a really,
really fun experiment. Um,
but we struggled a lot with it because
the video that we saw that inspired us to
do this, how did like a 10 inch spark
when you discharge the capacitor?
And we were like, yeah, we're going
to do that. It's going to be great.
And our first mark was like half
an inch and we're just like, why?
Why is that not working?
So we went through this process,
we found out things like even the,
like the little lip on the bowl we were
using was leaking a little bit of charge.
Um,
so we had to use a smoother bowl,
like so many neat little nitpicky things
that experimentalists would know better
than theorists. Um, so
it was, yeah, I think,
I think that this video for me was,
was a really good way to bring it
back to something that I love doing,
which is like problem solving,
learning through experience,
like spending a lot of time on something
and really trying to make it better.
In the end, we didn't get 10 inches. We
got four inches. Very cool. Awesome spark.
Yeah.
But we also happen to do this and like,
like historical rainy conditions
for San Diego. So like,
it's the middle of the, like the rainiest
month on, you know, the last few decades.
And we're trying to do static
electricity experiments.
Arizona.
This is going to be even cooler.
Yes. Or if you're somewhere cold right
now, like even in Tahoe or something,
it's probably a really good
time to do the experiment.
So anyone out there that does this
experiment Hashtag and send your video on
youtube to Diana.
Yes.
If you can beat my four inches,
you won't win a like or
subscribe or something. Sure. Uh,
so a close friend of mine is a physics
professor at Uc Irvine where he works on
longterm research and high energy,
high energy physics.
I'm always impressed by
the years of dedication.
Physicist applied are
really hard problems.
What is the most exciting
research you were following?
The could possibly reach a conclusion
in your lifetime or maybe not.
Yeah, I mean, I, I'm really shocked that,
that in the last couple years we've had
the discovery of the Higgs Boson and
then, uh, gravitational waves.
I'm guessing you guys have some nods if
you've heard of both of those. Awesome.
Yes. Um, so some gravitational waves
was something that I had heard about in,
in Undergrad. And they're like,
yeah, well they're working on Lego,
they're working on this detector.
And some of the professors that I studied
with were working on Lego and I was
like, wow, like this is really exciting.
Maybe in 20 years we're going to get
a detection and we're going to get the
discovery of gravitational waves.
But we have like,
that's so it's so exciting.
Like those,
those are the kinds of things I follow
are like the big discoveries that
actually make it to the um,
main stream news I guess. Yeah.
But, but in addition to that,
some of this stuff that I have worked on,
it's probably biases me to put paid
more attention to that research.
So like I worked on a dark
matter detection experiment
and so we're hoping to
detect dark matter sometime soon.
Hopefully in my lifetime
it may not happen,
but I think that's the next
gravitational waves. You know,
like if we could detect it'd be bigger,
it would be huge.
If we could detect dark matter
that would be like, you know,
like the gravitational wave detection.
It would just be amazing. Um,
I also worked on Lowman illicitly
stars, so like focusing on, uh,
the early universe. So
if we can, you know,
we'll learn more about like how stars
evolved as we discover more stars and look
further back into the oldest
stars. That'll be really
exciting. Yeah. Just so much.
There's too much.
So, uh, I'm going to start pivoting
now to your becoming a youtuber and,
uh, this is the timely, since when I'm
in recent videos, your dad was in it.
Very cool. He was struck by lightning
twice, twice. That's a cool video. Yeah.
I wouldn't want to
recreate that particular,
so I imagine the conversation with your
family that you've graduated from Mit
with a degree in physics and planned
to become a youtube creator would be an
interesting conversation.
Um,
imagine the path from MIT graduate
youtube creator was not a straight line,
probably had many dips in the polls
and the failures along the way.
What path did you take?
Yeah, so, um, yeah, my parents were not
super excited. They were like, okay,
hold up,
like we have to pay for this,
this degree from Mit.
Like I think that they thought that I
made pretty good life decisions up until
the point when I got my degree.
And then I was like, well,
I'm starting a youtube channel.
And I think like,
she probably thought that it was like
going to Hollywood or like maybe like a
reality TV show on,
on TV or something.
I don't think she thought very
highly of a youtube career. Um,
and it's not like I thought that that
would be my career when I started this.
But like, she's like, you're putting
your time into this. This is what you're,
you're trying to make,
go forward in your life.
That's not gonna go anywhere.
I'm just going to say it. Um,
but,
but as soon as I,
I think that it's worth saying that I
didn't just sort of drop everything and do
youtube. Like I was still
working different jobs here
and there. I was still, um,
I was still working at Ge doing software
engineering for a year and a half.
I still worked at Harvard doing research.
I worked at UC SD doing outreach there
and then worked at a science museum.
So I was never like,
like on the streets.
I wasn't like homeless
editing videos, but I, um,
I think I had this project though is on
the side and it was like I'm going to
put as much effort as I can on the side
while being a responsible human being
and having a job that's at least 10
generally related to what I want to do.
Cool.
So youtube creators are fascinating
because the learning process is documented
online. In preparing for this interview,
I've watched a lot of your videos.
Of course, they're all terrific,
including your earliest, which,
which you said over lunch
you don't watch very often.
So when I interviewed Kari Byron, she
mentioned that she didn't have any, uh,
theater training and learned on the job.
Was Theater ever in your background?
What was your learning process to
figure out how to be on camera,
which is not necessarily a natural thing.
Yeah,
I did actually did some theater.
I did musical theater up
until like middle school ish.
And then after that I did,
I did some performing,
but it was mostly like I
sang in an acapella group
and inquires and I played the
piano and stuff. Um, so I, I
had some performance experience,
but it was mostly singing.
It wasn't necessarily like I didn't have
a lot of speaking experience and that's
something that I've done a lot more than
I expected with starting. I was like,
Hey, this'll be great. I'll be alone in
my room filming in front of a camera.
And then I started getting invited to
speak to people in person and was like,
wait a minute. Not what I
signed up for. But it's,
it's more fun I think, honestly,
being in front of real people,
there's more a reaction from the lens.
So at the end of the day
you have to pay your bills.
Like everyone else you talked to about
how during the transition period, uh, you,
you were, had sort of a normal
day job, you know, how did you,
at what point were you able to say youtube
is my career as opposed to youtube is
something I'm pursuing and figuring
out what and what made that possible.
So yeah, like you said, my very
first videos are cringe worthy. Well,
he didn't say that. I didn't
say that. I mean I, I'll say it
and they're still, they're still up there
on youtube so you can check them out.
But um, but I think that it's
important to see, like I, you know,
I learned so much through the
process of doing this, um,
and no one was going to be paying me
or giving me any funding to make those
videos. They kind of started as
like skit videos more than they did.
They were like nerdy skits. It was
like, what to do with a physics degree.
And then I stood on my diploma to have
like that much height increase to stand
up and get something on a top shelf or
I used my diploma to like row about,
which could be useful now with all
the flooding and California. Um,
but uh, but yeah, I, I they were more,
they were more skits and it didn't
start out as like a science channel.
It started out as something else.
But once I kind of veered it into
the science channel and I was like,
I've wanted to do science communication.
Um,
I entered the flame challenge,
which is the science communication
competition and like video competition.
And I won that,
that got picked up by UCF news cause
I was working there and then I,
UC SD alum was working at PBS,
um,
and he's saw the article,
he was like, Hey,
we should get in touch
about you working with PBS.
And so now I'm signed with Pvs. I,
they're my sponsors and they, um,
I'm part of their PBS
digital studios networks.
So that was when it became like full time.
I got funding from PBS,
but like it was really like serendipitous.
There was a lot of
lucky steps that happen.
Like if that hadn't seen the article or
how to add an entered the competition,
I wasn't going to enter. I was like,
it's for scientists and I'm not,
I'm not working as a scientist. And my
advisor was like, are you kidding me?
Did you ever do scientific research?
And it's like, yes, he's like,
enter that competition. I am so glad
he told me to and made me do that.
Cause it ended up, you know,
this like lucky chain of events.
So for the,
uh,
over half a million subscribers and
many more millions of fans you have.
Describe a typical week as a youtube
creator. If there is a typical week.
Um,
well I answer a lot of emails just like
everyone else and it eats away at my
soul. Um, I, I,
I would say that,
you know,
there's a pretty typical schedule that
goes from like doing research to editing,
to animating,
to like putting up a video.
But there are some unusual times,
like I still, I have deadlines, um,
with PBS and so I still wait until the
last minute and I'm up until 4:00 AM like
I was in college, uh, finishing that
video that needs to go out the next day.
So I still do that.
I'm still like every once in a
while there's some audio missing.
And so I'm like in my closet
recording the voiceover,
which conveniently it has
good soundproofing cause
there's all the clothes
hanging around.
So sometimes I'll just go in there.
So you can imagine this is what you could,
should imagine physics girl.
Like I sit in my closet on the ground
with my recording equipment and I'm like
the capacitor.
So that's part of what the job is like.
So what video are you most proud of?
Even if it wasn't your most viewed,
which is probably your most viewed.
It's still in the vortex videos. Yeah,
probably. But what do you most proud of?
Even if it wasn't your most viewed video?
Um, well I'm pretty, I'm pretty proud
of the one that I just put out. Yeah.
Cool. I, I think it came at a
time where I was feeling like,
like it's starting to get to like a
routine of making videos and this has been
my hobby and now it's my career.
So for it to get kind of routine is like
I was having a little crisis for awhile.
I was like this, I can't, I can't have
it be like a career. I can have it.
Well it is, I mean I can't have it
be just like to routine and, and,
and get to the point where I'm losing
interest. So this video for me,
it was like I'm going to sacrifice a
few sleepless nights to spend more time
making this experiment and working
with my, uh, my intern on it.
And so like having that kind of
fun back and forth, I don't know.
And so I'm really proud that I made
the effort to take a step back from the
schedule and the routine to do something
that took more effort and took a lot of
failing.
And I'm pretty proud of that process.
Well, we'll send a maker element
of it was, was really cool.
So as was a fan of your table more
and more and more. It's awesome.
So has it gotten easier,
harder,
and you've kind of touched on this just
a in the last question is you've gone
from tens and followers to
half a million plus plus plus.
Yeah, I would say that it's
probably gotten harder. Um, I,
I think it's like, uh, like
I feel like the more I,
the more I do, the more I want to do and
I want to like, it's like working out,
you know, like as you get stronger the
more you want to lift, I imagine. Yeah.
I also imagine,
I also know,
I mean I do go to the gym
darn time, but I'm more of a
runner. Um, but I, yeah, like,
like the more I do,
the more I like,
I want to push myself and I want to
make better videos and longer videos.
And so I feel like instead of like,
I have a very experience I can,
I can sit back and it's easy.
It's more like I just want my videos to
be better and better and improve more
and more. And I feel more of that
pressure as the audience grows too. Yeah.
Um, so how do you calibrate the level
of detail and complexity for each video,
which cover wildly divergent topics.
And what role does feedback
from your audience play? One,
which I assume you get lots of
feedback across the whole spectrum.
Yes. Oh, those commenters.
Um, yeah, some of the feedback is,
is really good.
Um,
there's one comment that stands in my
mind and it was pretty trolley but,
but like came at the right time.
So I had made some of these videos
and then I made a science video.
Science should video and then I
made some more skit videos and um,
the name of the channel back then was
actually physics woman, but I was like,
I'm too, I'm not mature
enough for that name. So, um,
so someone was like,
you had a good idea what the channel with
like the science theme and making the
science content, you should have stuck
with that. And I was like, hmm, yeah,
maybe they were right. Like I, I,
I hadn't thought of making a science
specific channel, but that helps me lead.
That helped lead me to the thought
process. Um, but at the same time,
there are comments that
frustrate the crap out of me.
Like I made a video about why mirrors
flip appear to flip things horizontally
and not vertically.
Um,
which is an interesting question and
it's something that Fineman thought about
and wrote that he did like an
interview about it. Um, I asked,
I was living with at the time with a
number of physics graduate students,
one of them right there. Um, uh,
and so I asked them, you know,
I asked them this question
and they were like, like,
does it have to do with
your eyes being horizontal?
Or like they were thinking about
the, um, the, you know, the diag,
the optics diagrams.
Um,
and then I made this video and it's
actually kind of a complicated answer.
Um, and most of the comments
were like, are you kidding?
This is a video about how mirrors work.
This is something you learned
in first grade. And I was,
I was blown away that people were
saying condescending stuff like that.
But also they were wrong.
Like it's a hard question
and it's something that I
bet most of them wouldn't be
able to answer when put on the spot.
So,
so like some of the feedback you
have to take with a grain of salt,
uh, your video explaining why perpetual
motion machines are impossible.
What was terrific as a terrific video.
What are the most common physics smiths
you keep debunking despite all the
videos you put out?
Well, yeah, there's the perpetual that
physics is not cool. That's a good answer.
That's a myth.
Um,
I don't really do a lot of debunking
on my channel. I would say like I did,
I definitely did that one,
but I think that was maybe one of the
only videos where I did debunking.
And I think, I think partially
that's, um, that's on purpose that,
that like, I think questions are
important to encourage and I think that,
um,
every time I see a good question,
I make an effort to point out.
That's a really good question.
If it's not as good of a question,
I'll still be like,
thank you for asking because it's never
going to be like a negative experience
when someone has asked a question.
So,
so misconceptions are
interesting to address,
but I think it's more fascinating and
more interesting to figure out why those
misconceptions are common and why
they persist. Oh, cool. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, so you mentioned any youtube posts.
I think it was a Q and a poster that, uh,
it can be a lonely job
being a youtuber times. Um,
there's a strong youtube community of
creators that you tap into or is it
collaborative, competitive? Uh,
what's it like being a youtuber
and that loneliness factor?
Yeah, I would say the day to day gets
a little bit, um, a little bit lonely,
although less so lately because I've
started working with more people. Um, I,
I have a team, but, um, but yeah,
there's a big youtube community,
uh, in science as well. Um,
we're all spread out, which makes
it a little bit difficult. Like,
there's some people in Texas, I'm
in New York and some in La, um,
some up here in San Francisco, but, um,
never have I felt competition with them.
Like I've only ever felt support from
bigger channels or kind of excitement
towards smaller channels and,
and you know,
we always call each other and
ask advice and we're like,
what do you think about this
title? And we're like, no,
that's pretty boring or that, that
thumbnail is bad. Don't do that. Um,
so I think that we've, um, I think
we've been much more collaborative than,
than competitive and we all
meet up foot at Vidcon, um,
for the last couple of years at least
I've gone and we like play board games and
you know,
it's as nerdy as you would imagine.
So, uh, this is probably
affects everyone you tuber. Um,
how do you know where to draw the line
between your personal private life and
the need to be engaged with your fans?
Yeah. Um, I,
I don't have a lot of
trouble sharing things.
Like I don't have a ton of skeletons
in my closet, so like I'm a nerd.
It's out there and like I'm wearing a
pie scarf, you know, everyone knows.
Um, but, but I think, you know more,
I'm worried about the people in my life.
So like now that I have on the
other social media channels,
like Twitter and Instagram and Facebook,
I'll get more personal,
but I'll be more careful
about like posting a picture
of my sister or posting a
picture of my friends because I'm like,
you know,
thousands of people may see this and
you should know that before I posted,
is it okay? And usually they're
like, yeah, cool. So, um, so that's,
that's more of what I worry about.
But as a science host,
people aren't so much into like my day
to day life that it's more about like
we're sharing the science and like we're
exploring the science together and yes,
I am a person who does science and
there's some, you know, um, side effects.
Like I'm, I, I'm a woman in
a male dominated field of,
of physics and of science communication.
So like I get,
I get people reaching out and being like,
my daughter loves your channel and,
and thank you for being that role
model, um, for, for my daughter. So,
so like in that way, like having the
personal aspect of me as a person,
being a scientist come out
is a good thing, but I'm,
people want to know what I do everyday.
It's pretty boring. So in my closet,
pivoting off the, you know, the,
the mom or dad reached docs,
her daughters has been impacted.
So how do you view your role in helping
breakthrough this persistent myth about
women and stem?
I think, I think that
I'm making, you know,
a small contribution. Um, I,
I was just at a science
teacher conference, um, in,
in Virginia and then the teacher
on the teachers there was like,
I show your videos in my f my fifth
grade class. Then they love the videos.
And I was like,
interesting.
Like I'm curious how they react and I
just asked the question because I wanted
to know like how fifth graders at that
age would react to physics videos.
But she told me a different story,
which was that when I first watched it,
it was a video with, um, my,
my boyfriend Kyle holding
the stack of three balls. Um,
and then you dropped those.
And then I explain how that works
and how it's like a supernova.
So their reaction was cool,
why is she talking?
They thought that he should be the
host and I should be like the assistant
because that's what they typically see,
um,
is like there's a male host doing science.
And,
and she was really taken aback by
that response with her class. Um,
so was I, but, um, but,
but I think that it was good and it
started a big conversation with them.
Like they realize, oh, this
is her show, this is her idea.
She has the science background.
And it was a good opportunity for them
to have a conversation about this and
kind of break the idea of the
stereotypes of what girls can do. So,
um, I'm, I'm happy that those
conversations are happening in classrooms.
So one more question from
me. They're going to hand it
off to the Dory in the, uh,
the audience here.
So I interviewed Emily Cowans Reli
recently who is going to be unbilled eyes,
new Netflix series. You also had
a chance to partner with Bill Nye.
Is He as cool and energetic as he appears?
He's quirky,
very quirky.
Um, yeah, I did. I filmed a video
with him and actually I met him. Man,
my life has taken a turn. I met him
at the White House. I got, I was,
I dunno how I ended up there. I probably
won't end up there anytime soon, but
it was good while it lasted. Um, so I,
I was at the White House and Bill Nye was
there. Um, this wasn't a dream, I swear.
I mean they like it was, but
it was true. Um, so, so there,
when I met him, I, he was like,
because texting and whatever,
and I came up and I was like, Hey, bill.
And I was holding my phone and he thought
that I would want it to take a selfie.
So he's really a lot of selfies. And so
he grabbed my phone at 10. I was like, no,
I just want to like talk to you. I
love you. So, so that interaction was,
was he loves selfies.
So that's my first impression.
The second impression when
we, when we worked together
on a video, he's just like,
he's very excited about science and he'll
love to share like things he has like
toys, he has like my earrings,
you know, he's, he's like that.
He's got that real kind
of excitement for science.
And then the third time I got to watch
Emily's taping of villain I shows that
was really exciting and he
remembered me and I remembered him.
So it was mutually good. Uh,
yeah, it felt nice. Great. Cool.
Hi, very nice to meet you.
My, uh, daughter and I are
both subscribers and, uh, yes,
exactly. What you mentioned
about two questions ago.
You're inspiring a young women
to get interested in science.
Does she have her own account
or are you skewing the results?
Uh, no, she didn't. She has her own
account. She, she's uh, she's 14.
One thing I've noticed though is I
think when she was like 11, 12, 13,
she was much more excited. Now she's 14,
she's getting less excited about physics.
What kept you interested and how can
I inspire her to stay interested?
What are you thoughts on that?
Yeah. Ah, that's such a hard question
because cause like, you know,
you can do as much as you want,
but there's so many societal pressures on,
on women, um, to not continue
on with the sciences.
Um, I personally had throughout
high school I have these
teachers that were just
like, you are awesome at math,
you're really good at science. And I,
I remember so vividly when my,
my astronomy teacher told me that girls
who do physics are cool. And I was like,
I want to be cool because at that point
I had never experienced being cool. Um,
so, so like it was the
encouragement and it was, um,
it was from my teachers. It was
from, from some of my peers, um,
to continue asking questions
and to continue exploring.
And I think like the
investigation of, of, um,
of questions about the world
in addition to the, um,
the support and encouragement of teachers
was probably what carried me through
to actually doing a physics degree.
If scientists march in Washington,
will you be there
man, that's so mean. Like I try so hard
not to get political on social media.
Um, it's, uh, I mean it probably
depends on my schedule, but,
um, probably, yeah, I mean, I, I'm, I,
I'm a huge supporter of science and the
freedom of scientists to do the science,
you know, the science that is important
to them, um, and nothing politicized. And,
um, and I, you know, I, I,
I don't want to say believe in climate
change because it's just a fact.
Like it's just like the science
is there. So, um, so like I,
climate change is a hugely important
issue to me and it's something that's,
that's currently not looking
good for being addressed by,
uh, by, you know, politicians
taking power. So, sorry, smarts.
If you brought your own science
experiment, that can be really,
that's got to happen. Forget
about any politics. Just
bring it, you know, to enter,
you have to have a science experiment
and it has to be cool. Yeah,
that would be a lot of dry ice.
I'll bring my,
my like my atmospheric co
two detector. Yeah, exactly.
What would you bring them here and doing
the science march will be your best
experiment. That would be,
that would work for walking.
Like this is an interesting challenge.
I actually have this experiment.
I almost brought it today. I should
have brought it. Ah Man. Um, it's a,
it's a PVC pipe with a bunch of wires
wrapped around it and then some LEDs
connected to the wires in a circle.
So it makes us a loop and then you just
drop a magnet through the PVC pipe and
all the LEDs light up. There you go.
So that's like the big marching Bhutan,
but it's like very nerdy. So
that'd be perfect. All right.
So we can make it very positive
science marcher experiments.
Another audience question.
Do you have a list of things you want to
try out? And that list is girls, girls,
girls, sort of Joe's. And do
you like stop and say, okay,
which video am I going to work
on this week or this month?
Or what's the procedure there?
And also do you compare
lists with Veritas,
yum and smarter every day and
say, oh, you also want to do this,
this and these sort of crosspollinate or,
yeah, yeah. That actually
happened recently because, um,
I did a video on a anti
bubbles which are like, oh,
you guys are all nodding.
Um,
which are bubbles, sort of.
They're, they're like, um,
instead of a shell of liquid
with air inside an air outside,
they're a shell of water with,
with, or a shell of air, sorry,
with water inside and water outside.
So they're anti bubbles.
It's a more fancy name
than the actual thing is.
But I was talking with a destined from
smarter everyday and he was like, oh,
I wanted to do a video
about something similar.
So I put my video off as
long as I could. Uh, but,
but I shouted out to his upcoming
video and he shouted out to mine.
And Derek have from very task name
happened to do one at the same time.
So Destin shout out to his video like
we all kind of keep track of what each
other is working on.
Um,
I really wanted to do a video
about how big a building,
how tall a building would be for the top
of it to be moving the speed of light
if relativity wasn't a thing.
Um,
and I was kind of looking through
right before I was about to post it.
I realize that vsauce had done a video
of something similar he talked about.
So it was like my goal, I'm putting out
a video similar to yours. He's like,
that's fine. Just do it. Like we're all,
I think we're all very supportive of,
of overlapping topics and we're all
going to address things differently. Um,
but for your first question,
I do have a long running list and I've
been sticking more and more things on it
that are like go in the zero g plane
or go to Antarctica or you know,
so I'm not going to be able to do a
lot of those things, but I'm trying,
trying to make it happen.
Another story question,
what kind of reaction does you channel
get from people outside of the UAE? USA?
I have a, a large audience
in India actually. Um,
more so on my Facebook page then on my
youtube channel, which is interesting.
Um, I guess the same reaction.
I think sometimes they're like,
can you put some titles? Can you, uh, um,
yeah, I mean I would say the reaction
isn't much different for the international
community. Like people ask
the same kinds of questions,
they ask the same kind of followup
questions in the comments.
They make the same kind of snarky comments
about my sticky out ears or whatever
it is rude.
Uh, since you're at Google, might
as well ask this question. Uh,
what's one feature you
wish was added to youtube?
Oh, interesting. Well,
the algorithm recently changed.
So that led to part of my existential
crisis because I'm on this,
this is man, this is getting
personal, but like I, I'm,
I'm on this terrible platform where
like my quantitative success is,
um, is measured by like my views and
my subscribers and then those plummeted
recently with the
algorithm change. So, um,
I wish they would roll it back, but,
but no, I'm just kidding. I really,
I honestly think that that kind of was
like a wake wakeup call for me and the
one of the reasons why I did the most
recent video because I was like starting
to get into this routine and I was like,
I need something that's like for me.
And I'm really enjoying this
for the purposes of doing
it. And so I'm glad that,
that I've, it's kind of made me
move back toward that, you know,
that approach to making videos.
Um, other than that, uh,
I, I don't know. I, I, I'm pretty
happy with everything that's on there.
There's not much I, I do on other
areas that I don't, that I, you know,
would it be able to do on Youtube?
Like on,
I used Dropbox and I use Google for other
things and I use some of these other
services, but I don't think I would want
youtube to store my documents. I Dunno.
I love the collaboration. Yet there
was a song about Newton and Einstein.
I just hadn't realized
you had seen background.
Do you have plans to do
any more physics songs?
Oh yes. Oh my gosh. So I don't know if,
I don't know if this would actually like,
this would probably be one of those
cringey videos that I made earlier on,
but I was, so, it was, uh,
it was in the car driving
with my boyfriend the other
day and he wasn't paying
attention to me. So I started singing,
I started singing, but like, you know,
bringing jobs on roses and I was
started, I was like, what if you put,
could put physics lyrics to that.
So I was like,
I was like classical physics
and quantum mechanics.
These are a few of my favorite things.
So,
so it was like maybe I could make a song
out of that and make it go somewhere
and it'd be really, really
goofy. But maybe, I dunno,
maybe I might do some more.
Uh, what were some memorable failures
when you were starting your cheque?
Clearly unprompted questions.
Memorable failures. Oh, well, I have,
um, I have, I'm put some
errors in my videos.
Like I've had to literally take the
whole video down and I've, you know,
I stupid some,
some of that stupid stuff.
Some of it was like I actually
had misconceptions. Um,
so those were really good learning
moments for me. But also like,
sometimes it's just like I put an
arrow the wrong way and I'm like, ah,
that's so frustrating.
Um,
but fortunately the whole physics brigade
is there to tell me when I'm wrong.
Uh, another memorable
error? Uh, probably not. Uh,
remember with fairly when
I was working at UC SD, um,
I got this $9,000 grant for us to do some
outreach projects and they gave me the
tech and they presented it in this big
celebration. And then I lost the check.
Oh, I lost him. $9,000 check. That was
meant for you. CSD outreach for kids.
And I felt horrible and really
irresponsible. And like everyone else,
I got these grants, they were
like, you know, older. They,
they were, I don't know,
probably in their forties or 50s and
I'm like this 20th something that's like
give me the tech,
I'm going to do outreach,
I'm going to leave this whole
project of like science camps.
And then I lost it and it was like,
this does not look good,
but they just issued another check
and then I found it. Oh terrible.
In terms of platforms,
so you sort of stumbled into
youtube cause it was easy to do.
You could sit in your closet,
make your video and whatnot,
but did you sort of look forward,
there are lots of different channels
to make content on. There's Amazon,
there's Netflix, you know, maybe
apple, you know, who knows.
What are your thinking is on that front.
Do you think you'll stick with youtube?
What are the challenges, opportunities?
How does that all fit in?
Yeah, that's a really good question. Um,
I think that Facebook is,
uh, you know, they're, they're
pushing really hard with
video right now and there,
um,
some of my videos do really
well on Facebook when they
don't do well on Youtube.
Um, like the exact same video,
we'll just get many more views.
And now that might be view inflation.
I don't know.
It's hard to tell at this point. Um,
but then other ones where, you know,
cut down into a certain way that's
more Facebooky and less educational,
which to me is kind of like, uh, um,
but that works well on Facebook and so
that helps bring more of the audience
back over to Youtube,
which I think we'll probably
always be my first love,
but I would love to do more, you
know, more shows that are bigger.
I've got some ideas for, for
like bigger projects, um,
that would maybe work better on a
different platform. I don't know.
No, I don't do any PBS TV.
No. I am PBS digital studios,
so they only have youtube
channels and then, uh,
they're kind of separate entities. Well,
I guess they're underneath PBS umbrella,
but they're separate from the PBS
broadcast network shows. Cool.
Well, I want to thank you for
taking time out of your busy, busy,
busy schedule,
which I know is very busy from all the
work into create in the awesome stuff.
If you are not a subscriber,
subscribe.
If you're watching on our
livestream where later on Youtube,
go check out physics girl on Youtube,
and thank you very much for
sharing your story today.
[inaudible].